it's here you said you were nervous when
we were with you a couple weeks ago how
are you feeling in this moment it's so
exciting I'm still a little bit nervous
I just want to go back there richer and
get the numbers I heard that it's almost
already sold out
yeah I just feel like to know everything
like the numbers was what sold out the
most mm-hmm is it a family night out for
you tonight is off set here's culture
hares are you flying solo um I didn't
want to bring culture here because it's
just such a long flight and then after
this I got a flight to Miami and I know
that her ears be popping on the plane so
I'm like i'ma just keep her home because
in two days I'm gonna be back in New
York anyways and also she'll be coming
he said he was gonna come okay good your
first Mother's Day is coming up what are
you doing to celebrate I am so sad that
I checked my schedule and I'm booked for
Mother's Day I'm giving people a very
hard time for booking me on Mother's Day
because it's like I don't know like I
was just I just had like amazing plans
for Mother's Day like I wanted like to
wear something very lilac and match for
my daughter probably go to brunch for my
with my husband I like with my mom and
it's just like I can't do any of that
but I hope South Carolina turn up yeah
my favorite things about you is how
honest you are about everything and you
just made this big revelation about
getting liposuction why was that
important for you to share it was
important to me to share you know what a
lot of people was just like egging me on
to do it even though I was going to do
it because I really want to explain to
people how hard is to process I feel
like a lot of people look at girls on
Instagram and think like oh they got the
lipo done and it was so easy and it's
just such a long hard process it's
almost like the same process as after
you give birth to a baby and you seen
your body change and snapping it back
it's the same way but I will talk later
about it more
I don't know documentary oh maybe I
should start filming it right I should
start filming I should start filming the
process because this crazy anything else
you want to confess to
no nothing nothing I don't know if you
saw but Britney Spears is working out to
your song
I know it's old though because I'm a
very big Britney's pretty Spears fans
like I used to go on school like I miss
this oh my god that [ __ ] is shameless
cause [ __ ] used to hate on me in high
school oh my god I need that Britney
cardi collab what they do you have a
message for her right now what she's
going through
I love you and I totally understand I
fame will really drive you insane family
not only will Fame drive you insane but
it's like once you have money and
everybody just wants to take it from you
or sometimes like you just have your own
personal problems like when you a
celebrity everyone I want to sue you
everybody want a piece of the money that
you work for it's very frustrating and
then you have like the whole world
looking at you when no privacy is crazy
is and I can't imagine if you do it for
such a long time like her yeah speaking
of privacy you looked amazing at the Met
Gala what celebrities were coming up to
you inside uh-oh bunch I don't like
talking about people
[Music]